tables i got staples in my back staples
speaking from a hospital bed jacob blake
described his
constant agony 24 hours every 24 hours
is pain it's not my pain it hurts to
breathe it hurts to sleep it hurts to
move from side to side it hurts to eat
blake was shot in the back by a kenosha
wisconsin policeman in august
he's had numerous surgeries and is
paralyzed
the state's department of justice is
investigating the shooting
i just want to say man to all the young
cats out there and even the older ones
older than me
it's a lot more life to live out here
man
[Music]
in rochester new york protesters clashed
with heavily armed police
police used chemical irritants against
protesters who had launched
fireworks at them
[Applause]
some protesters formed a human chain and
there were several arrests
the demonstrators were demanding justice
for daniel prude who died in march
after police restrained him held him on
the pavement
and put a mesh hood over his head
prude's death was
ruled a homicide
the new york attorney general announced
she would impanel a grand
jury as part of what she termed an
exhaustive investigation
into prude's death seven
rochester police officers involved in
the killing have been suspended
[Applause]
in louisville kentucky black lives
matter demonstrators continued their
protests
over the death of brianna taylor shot by
police in her home
in march the protesters gathered outside
a race track where the prestigious
kentucky derby horse race was run
armed counter protesters calling
themselves pro-police patriots
confronted the black lives matter
marchers there was
arguing and yelling but no violence
as the patriot group eventually withdrew
and in portland oregon more protests
over police misconduct and systemic
racism
continued for the 100th consecutive
night
portland has come to symbolize the most
extensive
nationwide protests the u.s has seen in
decades
over racial injustice as the summer
season
draws to its clothes the u.s faces a
long hot holiday weekend of protest
rob reynolds al jazeera